so we have two different economies
depicted here on the Left we have an
economy where it's short-run equilibrium
output is above its full employment
output and so it has a positive output
gap and it might seem like a good thing
that your economy is just doing really
really well even more than what is
actually sustainable but there could be
negatives here as well you might be
depleting resources in an unsustainable
way you might start having uncomfortable
levels of inflation and so in these
situations if you don't have your
self-correcting mechanisms happen to get
us back to our full employment output a
government might want to do
contractionary contractionary fiscal
policy and it also might be because the
contractionary fiscal policy could undo
some expansionary fiscal policy that was
done in the past and we'll talk more
about that but what are examples of
contractionary fiscal policy
well contractionary fiscal policy you
could raise taxes raise taxes that would
decrease aggregate demand or you could
decrease spending decrease spending and
if you think about it what it would do
to these curves it would shift our
aggregate demand curve to the left the
goal would be to get back to our
long-run equilibrium so you would want
to get to this aggregate demand curve
too through your contractionary fiscal
policy now if you look at the right we
have the opposite scenario here we have
a negative output gap sometimes known as
a recessionary output gap and
governments tend to get more worked up
about the recessionary output gap
because now people are out of work
things are not good and so what would a
government want to do if the regular if
the if the self-correction mechanisms
aren't happening well they might want to
do expansionary fiscal policy
expansionary expansion Airi fiscal
policy and so they would want to shift
this aggregate demand curve to the right
so that it looks something
more like this we get back to our full
employment level of output so that would
be aggregate demand - and what are
examples of expansionary fiscal policy
what's going to be the opposite
you could you could lower taxes lower
taxes or you could increase increase
spending so let's focus on this the
expansionary monetary policies and
actually dig a little bit deeper into
the numbers let's say we have an economy
where our marginal propensity to consume
our marginal propensity to consume is
0.75 and let's say that we have a
negative output gap right over here of a
hundred billion dollars so we have 100
billion dollar negative or recessionary
out- output output gap let's first think
about the increasing increasing spending
lever how much would we have to increase
spending given this marginal propensity
to consume to close a one hundred
billion dollar negative output gap pause
this video and try to solve that well
let's just think about our multiplier
our multiplier or multiply multiplier is
going to be equal to one over one minus
the MPC so that's 1 over 1 minus 0.75
well that's 1 over 0.25 which is going
to be equal to 4 and so if you want to
close a hundred billion dollar spending
gap or should I write output gap so
that's your output gap you want to close
that's going to be equal to your your
spending increase so spending spending
increase spending increase times your
multiplier so in this case it is times 4
so if you divide both sides by 4 you get
that your spending your spending
increase is going to need to be 100
billion divided by 4 is going to be
twenty five billion dollars makes sense
if you spend if the government spends 25
billion dollars because
the marginal propensity to consume you
have a multiplier for so you have a
hundred billion dollars of more of total
spending that is going to happen in the
economy because of that initial
government spending of twenty five
billion dollars but what if instead the
government wanted to do it by lowering
taxes what would be the amount that they
would need to lower taxes once again
based on this very simplified model in
order to close this output gap well here
we want to think about the tax
multiplier our tax multiply multiply is
equal to our marginal propensity to
consume times our multiplier times our
multiplier times our regular multiplier
so in this case it is going it's
actually the negative of that because if
you increase taxes then that is going to
decrease spending and vice versa and so
this is going to be equal to negative
negative 0.75 times 4 which is equal to
negative 3 and so one way to think about
it is if we want to close a hundred
billion dollar output gap that is going
to be equal to delta T how much we
increase taxes times negative three if
we want to solve for Delta T if we want
to solve for Delta T we divide both
sides by negative three and we get delta
T so let's put a little arrow here delta
T is equal to one hundred billion one
hundred billion dollars divided by
negative three which is approximately
equal to negative thirty three billion
dollars once again why is this negative
well this is your increase in taxes so
if that's negative that means you
lowered taxes by thirty three billion
dollars so lower taxes by thirty three
billion dollars now there's a couple of
interesting things here other than just
the mechanics and the numbers notice
that this number and this number are not
the same and that's a common
misconception that they would be the
same that they would be equivalent if
you're trying to close the same gap
notice they
art in general if we assume everything
we just assumed if you're trying to
close the same output gap you would have
to change your taxes by more than you
would have to change your government
spending